I was not interested in music I was
really trying to be the next Michael
Jordan of course I look at my music like
a soldier looks at his floor never put
your sword down in the midst of a war
I'm not that guy
if they miss music they ain't nut ain't
none like it used to be like that's when
you old that's when you outdated I'm not
as know Lena but the earth is my purse
when it comes to this video he's an
American singer-songwriter record
producer and former professional
basketball player he's recognized as one
of the best selling music artists in the
United States with over 40 million
albums sold he's been credited with
helping redefine R&B and hip-hop earning
the name the king of R&B
he's our Kelly and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success rule number one
is my personal favorite I'm curious if
your girl which one you guys like the
best and as always as he's talking if
you said something that really six
island is meaningful to you please write
it down in the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
I believe that the depth of anybody
struggle will determine the height of
their success and I believe that
everything that I've gone through in my
whole life you know people ask me what
would you change
I wouldn't change a thing because
everything that I've gone through it
made me who I am today
you know so I feel very strong is very
complicated you know and it got a lot of
love for a lot a lot of people Jesus
struggled and went through things you
know everybody went through the old day
and and people who slanted him I mean I
feel like if Jesus can go what he went
through
Who am I I'm nobody because there's a
guy from the lulav edges that just do
this music you know but it was just such
a real person I don't consider myself a
celebrity at all I'm just so real and I
love people that you know man I just
flow through this thing you know and I
let my music I'm that guy Gaby when you
got to be to go but God will just guide
you straight to success not God you
gonna crowd you through a lot of mess
first so that when you get the success
you know how to appreciate it you know
how to stay with it and know how to take
care of it not that and that's called
longevity and I know about your school
and another idea I'd like you to tell us
about who inspired you and encourage you
to do your music can you tell us a bit
about huh well as Lena McClendon like my
second mother and she's a pastor and
everything my teeth my music teacher in
high school in high school my freshman
year I was a star Don King with
basketball team's name on my high school
and but I happened to have a music class
at that point in time I wasn't and I
think I was about sixteen seventeen I
was not I was not interested in music I
was really trying to be the next Michael
Jordan of course and she told me that I
was saying you know I would be the next
Stevie Wonder or superstar Michael
Jackson or something like that and I and
I laughed at like she was crazy you know
I was I couldn't see it and everything I
am today she could see it my mother
could see it
and she would tell me that uh I was
going to be where I'm at today and even
farther so and it just had just happened
our she put me in a talent show and I
did the talent show and the girls are
screaming and everything I was like man
I don't get this kind of love on the
court you know and of course I'm going
to choose that over basketball and I did
and I've been doing it ever since
so what would you would you say that was
your big break or third stage a little
further down the line that was the
significant breakthrough music I would
say my big break is that point in time I
learned that keep you under uh risk I
was one of the steps because I felt like
man if I learned that I could learn
anything because that guy was going
pretty sad but as far as crowd rising
what nailed it I would say my first
talent show pretty much is what bit me
in a way like Peter Parker got bit by a
spider and became spider-man you know
that was that was the bike for me you
know when we when the women and
everybody was showing me so much love at
the talent show and I want and and I was
like wow it was overwhelming actually is
I shoot you I got my record deal I was
on stream stream
removing keyboard okay glasses on like
house TV one shake in our offices
husband you know little big [ __ ] in the
bucket I paid my rent and my mom's ring
it awful street performer but I'll only
do it three days out of the week just
three days when I was because I kept oh
I can't even talk because I was like
singing from night like eight hours
straight there are people going to work
and coming from work
hitchhike to LA but I've lived on the
beach you know cardboard box and nice
have a flip off it is on beach every day
then I wake back up
when I wake up my feet again
and I think I hitchhike back to Chicago
and then I got discovered I did all that
for mike scioscia streets for me what is
your secret just being very observed you
know I'm very observant of people you
know and my mom always told me don't
write songs write life you know and all
the ways only way you're going to write
life is that you'd be very observant of
people and always paying attention to
people and the needs of people and what
they what they're talking about these
days and you know and then kind of like
channeling that into your gift which is
my music so and I believe that as long
as I continue to be observing the people
and do that I be right for the
seven-year turmoil that you went through
Visa Visa trial for child pornography
your advisers almost to a person told
you over and over and over again while
you're going through this period
Carole's do not put out sexually
explicit material do not the audience
can't handle that your fans can't handle
it it's not going to be good for the
outcome of this trial tone it down
don't put that out you ignore all of
them do it anyway and get bold with it
it's during these periods you put out
chocolate factory you put out remix you
put out ignition here telling you not to
do this and you put out a song about
putting the old key in the ignition I
read that and I wanted to ask so I will
why is that you went against your
advisers what is it that you would think
is that you were feeling they kept you
doing that when everybody else told you
not to do that well first of all let me
say you know I wasn't bold about it you
know and I didn't totally ignore because
that would be the worst thing to do is
totally ignore your advisers or your
lawyers I listen to them we talk we
discuss the situation I felt strong very
strong as I said many years ago about
the trial that I will have my day in
court you know and now and I will be
innocent and I will walk away and I will
move on with my life I said that in the
beginning I said that during the middle
part of the trial and everything else
I look at my music like a soldier looks
at its floor you never put your floor
down in the midst of a war you never lay
down in the midst of a war and I think
that my lawyers were good lawyers great
lawyers but I didn't think they had that
part down and you have to be the soldier
in the midst of the war to even
understand that and I was the soldier on
the front line for my life for my kid's
life for my fans and I told them I would
not lay down I would not stop doing
music why would I do that I think that
would say oh yeah he did it I think that
would say all the things that people
want to say about our Kelly so I did
what I'm supposed to do like any fireman
it goes up in the building they don't
get to the building say oh wait a minute
that's just too much fire but you're a
fireman so go and fight the fire don't
care how much it is I had to go and I
had to do my music I'm not going to
change my lyric I'm not going to change
my name I'm not going to do any of that
I'm going to do my music and that's what
I did and that's what I told the company
even though they continued to say no
don't do it
but the minute ignition came out which
was the first song I did it blew up and
all of a sudden the company's called him
everybody's calling me come to an album
cover shoot we got to get the rest of
this I'm done we got to go there we got
a video go to the video code we don't
have a well I ain't got no dogs on make
a person you got to make up when y'all
make up with you when we look I mean it
just got crazy so I did what I felt was
right I started saying things like um I
can hear someone over there calling me
home crowd will just go crazy and I walk
now there I can hear someone over there
calling me oh-ho-hoo they go crazy just
before body calling was even it was born
you know they look gimmick like that and
on another cracker
come body and he's just amazing little
gimmick that work that I was doing on my
show I never thought that I would take
it into the studio and say okay I make a
whole song out of your body called it
your body's calling me but that's that's
how the song came about and then I think
the more I started doing that the more I
started deciding well I'm just going to
start saying what I feel because I would
always say on my stage do you mind if I
say what I feel right now they would
love it did I say what I feel so you're
feeling kind of holding right now and
they would snap you know and but that's
what I was feeling I say what I feel
people appreciate me keeping it real
with them and everybody wants to know
what you really feel you know it doesn't
means you know they want to know what
you really think it so I was giving them
what what was on my mind and on my heart
at that particular time you hear can you
find your niche they're really at that
point I mean it everybody a lot of a lot
of volunteer officers trying to do that
kind of thing that you kind of did it
just that bit better
well I think because after I started
doing a lot of people would follow if
you don't mind I mean a lot of people
follow in a humble way I say that but
you know it was the difference when you
when you mean it you know you do it when
I came up with it it came out of me from
my belly and I did it because that's
what I felt
and that's what was on my mind other
other people when they when they did it
they were inspired to do it and it's a
difference you know it's a difference
and who created the light book and then
who turned at all it's a big difference
my music is still in me and it's and
there's more powerful now than there's
ever been because I don't know what
something didn't even but about me
really what it is it's just the weirdest
thing in the world I love usually going
to keep my ears close to music and I'm
always studying the new artists I'm not
that guy they say man this music today
ain't nothing ain't none like it used to
be like that's when you old that's where
your outdated but when you can
appreciate the newcomers you know as
well as you can appreciate the Stevie
Wonder's and the Sam Cooke's all in one
you kind of stay fresh and you kind of
stay up on what's going on and you can
be able to study it and continue to
upgrade your stuff you know a little
different than the iPhone you know it
comes with different apps and different
new things you know and that's what I
like to consider myself as I've got one
set process and how you make a song or
is it different with you every single
time it's different every single time
but at the same time you know I believe
in keeping it real you know and and when
I'm singing on these tracks
I don't really write the song I let it
write me so whatever it tells me to say
they say hey they chilling on your booty
booty I'm just afraid you know biggie
tell me to go say I know this don't
sound super but say boo boo boo boo boo
goes okay yeah I was going to yell you
know I'm gonna keep it real good enough
with the music tell me to do that's what
I much not to not to promote it to fans
what my book is called
are Kelly no Lane and what that means is
I'm not in no Lane I'm at the earth is
my turf when it comes to this beautiful
now yeah on the butter it's our Kelly no
lanes you know and because you know you
get put in the lane if you stay in one
lane man that's just really really where
you're gonna go that one Langone leads
you to one place ain't no particular
address that I'm going to ain't no
particular Street I want to ride on you
know and like I said it's my turf man
and that's my story and I'm sticking to
it
I had all his music posters everything
up I had Moonwalker plan on the video
screen and I would just go for the song
as I look at Mike I would sing what I
thought he could sing you know I was
just mimicking what I thought he was
saying on the lyrics and everything and
then when he asked me is it anyways
come in here and and sing the
backgrounds with me I was like uh sure
yeah of course while yeah I'll be an
animator and I gotta walk down there I
got between the wall that he couldn't
see and I was like open the back up I
thought oh go ahead just like a little
girl man is just mess it up but we
standing there he you know I am here
with you and all I got to do really I'm
telling myself saying what you're saying
on the demo you idiot and you can't go
wrong because you silent like Michael
owned it anyway so I'm doing that I'm
I'm he's here right here like the same
mic we both got on headphones and I'm
going to nut alone how he look over me
other I am here with you this away I'm
here to stay - not alone you know I got
that let's shake it before yeah man I
was loud I was just blown away I'm
standing here singing with Michael
Jackson right here I'm right here I saw
the gravity but I want to do that I'm
going to do that you know it with the
same we are the world this is really
you're not alone don't do it so I
started to grab his hand it just just
just for good measure you know but I
can't do that but it was a great time
working with Michael man thank you guys
so much for watching I made this video
because Ruby Watson asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it down in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do I'd also love to know what was
the biggest lesson that you learn from
this video that you're going to
immediately apply to your life for your
business leave it in the comments I'm
going to join in the discussion finally
I want to give a quick shout at Ariel's
live
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book dear one word and then flying
to Toronto to meet me to get it signed I
was a fun day I really appreciate it so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe
self and whatever your one word is much
love I'll see you soon